Hey youtubers it’s charlie and the other
day I asked everyone to submit all their questions
about the new deathstroke, the flash and all
things arrow season 2, so here’s my first
of many arrow Q&As this year.
Since making longer videos has made harder
to do a greater number of videos each week
I also comment on community and american horror
story after the q&a part.
So think of this as also being a super catch
up video.
I’ll be changing my upload schedule soon,
but I’ll post a video explaining.
So be sure to subscribe to get it.
and follow me on twitter for updates at robot
challenger.
Let’s get going, question number 1 - Mikhail
Pace asks Who will be the first Flash Villian?
In the most current origin story it’s savitar
that killed his mother.
But surprise surprise it turns out professor
zoom is behind it all.
So professor zoom will always be the flash’s
version of the joker.
The most infamous villain.
But they’ll also have a medium bad, someone
like brother blood.
So we’ll meet that person first.
It will probably be one of the rogues.
Question 2 - Jak Gibson (no avatar) asks What
mask do you think is better the one from the
island or the new one﻿?
I like the new one the best, the old mask
was just a piece of cloth and I hated the
black and yellow colors together.
I like the new burnt orange steel look better.
I would have been happier if they had stuck
with the yellow and blue color scheme from
the comics.
Question 3 - Ignacio Cotto (no avatar) asks
Could this be Oliver’s father come back
via the lazarus pit in an episode or are you
fully convinced he died?﻿
I think that Merlin being thea’s father
is the only ‘empire strikes back’ father
twist we’ll be seeing this season.
I always thought of Oliver’s father as a
normal person who became a victim of the shadow
world.
I don’t think they’ll bend the canon to
make him some supernatural character.
Lazarus pit style.
I think Raysh is the only one the writers
would allow inside the lazarus pit.
Question 4 - Jesus Reyes asks Do you think
arrow will talk to deathstroke about the island?
Definitely, we haven’t even gotten to the
episode where slade loses his eye and they
haven’t destroyed the mirakuru yet.
So there’s a big island battle coming still.
And he and slade are still friends, so slade
will have to start blaming oliver for shadow’s
death at some point.
Queston 5 - delenayel asks When do you expect
Barry to wake up from his coma?
During the pilot episode of the spin off.
If they had not decided to just do a full
pilot episode and had used episode 20 as the
backdoor pilot like they originally planned,
that would have been when he woke up.
Question 6 - jack thao (no avatar) asks Do
you think Deathstroke is part of the league
of assassins storyline if so, What if the
show-runners go the grant Morrison path and
do a son of batman story twist...
But with the Arrow, Where deathstroke tries
to take over the league of assassins by kidnapping
some sort of love child oliver queen had or
maybe Robert queen had one and it's Oliver's
half Brother...
(The creators switch the Conor Hawk origins
around he becomes Oliver's half brother...)
do you think it would work?
I don’t think deathstroke is part of the
league, he was special forces, so he was already
a trained assassin.
And with the mirakuru he would have just eventually
learned to control his new abilities.
I don’t think that they’ll introduce any
new characters, so Deathstroke will probably
end up kidnapping Felicity and try to turn
her against Oliver.
Remember, he said ‘corrupt those he loves’
and destroy those who work with him.
So he’ll try to corrupt Felicity and destroy
Roy.
And Barry, if he comes back for the finale
with flash superpowers.
Question 7 - Daniel Sezanayev (no avatar)
asks Do you think that Oliver should also
get injected with the Mirakuru?
In my opinion the villains are just too powerful,
plus now Roy is stronger than him?
No I don’t think so, one of the big aspects
of green arrow and batman are that they do
not have superpowers.
They’re just normal people who are so good
they can be just as effective with superheroes.
If they gave him super powers it would diminish
his eventual triumph over slade.
It’s like saying, real hero’s don’t
need super powers.
Question 8 - Galaxy Ronin (no avatar) asks
anything you know about the upcoming show
" Gotham"﻿
Yes, they’ve started casting the non-super
hero roles.
It’s going to feature Bruce Wayne when he’s
really young.
Like before the events of Batman Begins, he’ll
probably be a teenager.
Fox paid Warner Brothers a dump truck of money
so that they could use major super heroes
and characters from the comics.
So it will be really cool.
I’ll be doing weekly videos for it, but
it won’t air until the fall.
So I’ll start doing previews for it around
comic con this summer.
Question 9 - Mitch Panthera (no avatar) asks
Do you think Oliver will fully train Roy?
And what will his name be?
This is going to be an empire strikes back
luke skywalker situation, where by Oliver
Yoda will start Roy’s training.
But it took Oliver and even slade years to
become experts, so Roy will complete his training,
return of the jedi style as the show goes
along in future seasons.
So Roy’s not going to become a jedi level
fighter this season.
Oliver is just setting him on the path to
becoming Red Arrow.
He’ll be wearing a red hoodie next week,
so I think they’ll do the same thing they
did for Oliver, They’ll just call him the
red vigilante or something like that.
It won’t be exactly like the comics.
And they’ve already called Thea speedy,
so it definitely won’t be that.
Question 10 and last one: Kyle McKenna asks
Wouldn't Roy be a good match against Slade?
I mean they both have the serum and once Oliver
trains him they'll be pretty even.﻿
Roy is untrained and Slade has a lifetime
of experience as an assassin.
And he’s had the last 6 years to get used
to the effects of the mirakuru serum.
Just because you become super strong and super
fast doesn’t mean you automatically learn
to be an expert fighter.
So Roy will probably try to take on slade
and get his ass kicked.
The finale will probably be a three on one
fight with slade versus oliver, black canary
and roy at the same time.
Thanks for submitting questions you guys,
this was a lot of fun.
Don’t worry if I didn’t get to your question
I’ll be doing these every week.
I’m changing my upload schedule to make
it a little easier to do bonus videos like
this more.
Be on the lookout for my Emergency Awesome
channel updates video next week.
It will explain everything.
Since a lot of you have been asking and since
I missed them last week here’s a couple
of quick thoughts on Community and American
Horror Story.
Community first: 1 - troy is off the show
for good now.
He left because he’s making his own comedy
show that we probably won’t get to see until
next year.
It’s called Atlanta and it will be on FX.
2 - I’m really liking season 5 so far.
The ratings haven’t been great so far, but
NBC has said that there’s still a chance
for a 6th season.
3 - Did you hear when Chang screamed Nathan
Fillion as his same sex celebrity crush during
the episode.
In addition to just being funny it’s also
a nod that he’s going to be in next week’s
episode.
It’s called analysis of cork-based networking.
Abed’s girlfriend from last season will
also be back.
She’s played by Brie Larson, who’s amazing.
4 - Because i just spent a few sentences talking
about how amazing the episode is going to
be I’m going to try and move heaven and
earth to do a separate video just for the
episode.
If you have any specific questions about the
episode just post them in the comments for
this video.
On to American Horror Story - careful for
spoilers, because a lot of really big stuff
happened.
Number 1 - They implied that fiona is gator
bait.
This is just a way for the writers to say
that misty can’t bring her back.
So I believe that she’s actually dead.
But we might still see her in the afterlife.
We did see Kathy bates and angela bassett
in hell, so I think fiona will appear but
only as a spirit.
Number 2 - The seven wonders.
Everyone will participate.
Remember that black and white film at the
beginning of the episode.
It told us that if you attempt the wonders
and you’re not the supreme, you’ll die.
So they want us to think that all of the girls
are going to die except for whoever the new
supreme is.
Number 3 - Supreme predictions.
I actually have three competing theories.
My first one is that it really is zoe and
she and franken kyle will live out their days
in magical bliss.
But, that would actually be a bit of a disappointment
from a story standpoint.
We’ve spent all season with each of the
girls saying I’m the one, no I’m the one.
Well what if none of them are the one.
And it’s someone we haven’t met.
There’s always a twist.
I just seems to convenient for it to be one
of them at this point.
The third theory is that it really is madison
and she’ll just become the next fiona.
Another terrible supreme that will destroy
the line of salem.
Think of that as like the apocalypse theory.
Like the worst possible outcome.
The show says it all in the title.
This is a horror show, so there are no happy
endings.
Even for spaulding and his creepy real life
doll baby.
So remember, I’m posting a big emergency
awesome channel update next week.
Especially since I’m almost at 100 thousand
subscribers.
You guys all deserve the highest of fives.
Right now click here for the actual episode
of arrow that this q&a was based on and click
here for anime club.
Coming tonight!
Thanks for watching, see you guys in a couple
hours.
High fives!